quelle est la différence entre un
champion de tennis au travail est un
champion de tennis en vacances aucune
pour jo wilfried tsonga dans les deux
cas il passe des heures raquette à la
main sur un court de tennis sauf que là
il s'amuse avec son petit frère en
revanche la semaine prochaine il
reprendra l'entraînement le vrai avec en
ligne de mire les championnats de france
15-16 ans à la fin du mois
j'ai fait du mieux que je peux gspr veut
gagner d'un tennis hampshire remis en
question quoi donc on n'a jamais même
après une victoire juste après on peut
repères pour
jouer c'est
certes niçois depuis un an jo wifried et
en sport études à l'insep de vincennes
où il s'entraîne quatre heures par jour
les résultats n'ont pas tardé le manceau
vient de remporter le titre de champion
d'europe des 15 16 ans ce qui lui a
permis de s'aguerrir ce sont aussi les
nombreux tournois juniors qu'il dispute
il ya un circuit un peu comme la tp qui
s'appelle vpf
donc un classement mondial
faut avoir beaucoup de points joue
beaucoup de tournois se passe beaucoup à
l'étranger donc on va jouer en amérique
les progrès du grand frère profitent
aussi aux plus jeunes les autres qui
sont plus tellement de fois que je
compte faire quand j'étais quand il tape
porsche plage arrive mais a renvoyé
attention à enzo surveillera de près les
performances de son aîné dans quinze
jours à roland garros
[Musique]